split is directed by M night Shyamalan
and this was one of the films I got to
see at AFI Fest it was a ton of fun he
came out introduced the film with a very
heartfelt speech there was also a
director and cast and crew conversation
afterwards and I want to reassure anyone
watching right now this is going to be
100 percent spoiler free I'm not even
going to hint at anything
no playful nudging I hate when critics
do that we're not dumb you're safe with
me this is going to be the type of
review that I would want to see if I
wanted to know about this movie because
I hate any and all spoilers you're safe
here let's talk about split and I just
want to give a special thank you to the
viewer who sent me this notebook and
this awesome pen as well as some other
things I took all my notes for this
review on this thank you very much you
are the best so after a moderate success
with the visit Shyamalan has returned to
his more traditional filmmaking roots to
make a psychological thriller starring
James McAvoy as a man caught in the
middle of disassociative identity
disorder he has 23 different
personalities living inside his head and
one of them has kidnapped three girls
he's holding them captive somewhere for
an undisclosed reason and the film cuts
back and forth between these girls
trying to figure out how to get out and
James McAvoy visiting Betty Buckley who
plays his psychologist if you guys have
been following my channel for a long
time you know that Sean Milan's films
have had a major impact on me if I
hadn't have seen some of his earlier
films I wouldn't be talking to you guys
right now that being said I've been a
supporter of him for quite some time and
save for the visit which as I said was a
moderate success
ever since the village I've been pretty
let down I got to say having seen split
it is a very good time to be a fan of M
night Shyamalan he is most certainly
back this is his best film since signs
it is a very very good psychological
thriller let's talk about what worked
about split the three main performances
in this movie James McAvoy Anna Taylor
joy who you may recognize from the witch
and Morgan and Betty Buckley I'll talk
more about McAvoy in a bit let's talk
about Betty Buckley first as this
psychologist she plays a woman who's
desperately trying to communicate with
James McAvoy's character and all the
various personalities that reside in his
head she's trying to figure out
how he works she's trying to dissect the
brain of someone who's dealing with this
to figure out how to cure him and how to
help him and I loved her character in
this film during the cast and crew
discussion with her she referred to
herself as the crazy old lady from The
Happening so I'm not calling her that
she called herself that and you might
remember her from that but she really
shines in this movie and brings a lot to
the film and Anna Taylor joy once again
is very good in this film this is
another very good turn from her even
though Morgan wasn't a great film she
was definitely one of the best parts of
it and she was fantastic in the Witch
and here in split she shows herself once
again to be one of the most exciting
talents of her generation my favorite
part of her character is that there was
a lot to discover there's a lot of
layers to peel back which we'll talk
more about later James McAvoy I feel is
one of the most underrated actors
working today I've liked him in
everything I've seen him in I think he's
excellent as Professor X but he's great
in smaller films like filth McAvoy is
insanely courageous in this movie he
gives himself 100% to this performance
he is fully committed in this role and
it pays off I think this is the best
performance I've ever seen from him each
personality is very distinguishable from
the rest just from his vocal patterns
and his facial mannerisms he's brilliant
in this film I think it's his best
performance if this came out this year
in 2016 and not next year in 2017 I'd be
saying nominate this guy right now I'm
serious he's that good in this movie one
of the things that Shyamalan brought up
in the directors discussion after the
film that really stuck with me is the
difference between portraying a
character that's fictional and
portraying a character from non fiction
like a biopic because you can look at
someone who's existed in real life and
then recreate their extreme more
over-the-top nature and it's sort of
safe with a fictional character like
this you just have to be out there you
have to fully give yourself over to the
director in the script and McAvoy did
that and he really really went for it
trust me what you've seen in the trailer
that's nothing he is so good in this
film when Shyamalan introduced the film
he mentioned that after he saw the movie
it follows he immediately tried to hire
the director of photography of that film
for
split and he got him and it shows this
is one of sha Milan's best looking
movies the camerawork is brilliantly
contained in claustrophobic the lighting
is superb this is a great looking movie
unlike sha Milan's previous movies safe
for the visit which featured no score at
all this film is not composed by James
Newton Howard is composed by West Dillon
Thornton who Shyamalan mentioned that he
hired after seeing the TV showed the
jinx because he thought the music was so
effective and what I loved about the
score for this movie is that it's very
subtle refreshingly so in fact sometimes
you won't even notice it creeping into a
scene slowly building an intense aura of
dread and it really worked
and ever since signs Shyamalan has tried
to incorporate humor along with the
thrills in his films sometimes it really
works and sometimes it really doesn't in
this film there's a great balance of it
he wisely pokes fun at some of the more
absurd elements of McEvoy's various
personalities and gets us to laugh when
we should laugh there's no uncomfortable
sequence where we feel like should we be
laughing right now or should we not
laugh the film knows when to make say
Hedwig the nine-year-old boy personality
in McAvoy considerably funny and it
knows also when to make that personality
frightening because just when you think
you're laughing at how cute the
nine-year-old boy version of James
McAvoy is all of a sudden you feel
terrified by that version of him there's
also a scene in this film which I will
simply refer to as a scene that involves
a CD player one of my favorite scenes in
the movie it's incredible and if you
watch very closely there's actually a
mini story being told that unfolds
throughout this sequence that Shyamalan
brought up in the directors conversation
and I can't wait to talk about that in a
future spoiler video easily my favorite
aspect of this movie is that Shyamalan
is putting a vast amount of trust in the
audience he sets up a lot of story
elements here and there that will not be
fully understood until we've seen the
entire film we learn things about
characters we learn things about
backstory and the big picture becomes so
much more impactful after we've seen the
movie and it makes you want to watch it
again through a different eye
that's what some of his best films were
like films that showed characters as a
fact this is the character this is how
they are as the film progresses you
learn why they're that way and it makes
it so much more impactful as we as
audience members begin to discover the
story on our own without just being told
everything we get to peel back the
various layers of these characters and
learn why they feel the way they do
he's strongly respecting the audience
here and assuming that we're going to be
on this ride with him he is asking us to
be patient and I think this is a film
that is going to weed out viewers who
have trouble with being patient in
movies because it's the type of film
that requires you to take various leaps
of faith with Shyamalan and if you take
those leaps you're going to be rewarded
I do have some flaws with split one of
them in particular being the two other
girls who are also in captivity with
Anya Taylor joy particularly hayley lou
richardson who i thought was very good
in edge of seventeen here though she's
very forced and sometimes over the top
she seems to be on another level from
anya taylor joys character and it
doesn't always work sometimes that's
because the film is focusing on our lead
girl and sometimes haley lou
Richardson's character gets drained into
the background but sometimes these other
two girls would just say things that
came off very out of character and
extremely wooden in the opening scenes
the opening few scenes are a little bit
clunky and sometimes the dialogue
doesn't really work there's also an
extensive exposition scene where Betty
Buckley's character is skyping into a
press conference where she's discussing
identity disorder and how people can
learn from it and the things that
certain people can do and this entire
sequence I felt could either be
significantly cut or removed entirely
and who knows I mean maybe by the time
it's officially released it will be I
don't know but I felt that sequence
really did not need to be in this movie
that was one of the few sequences that I
felt was not trusting the audience it
was more of a hey here's a whole bunch
of info think about this for a while
also as stated the film requires you to
take some major leaps of faith and as
you're watching certain things you might
be thinking I don't know about this but
if you just go with it
you're going to be rewarded trust me
because it was so well made that I was
like
right let's see where this goes and I
was pleased now I won't be discussing
the way the film concludes because as I
said 100% no spoilers what I will say is
that it's in my top two favorite endings
to any Shyamalan film it's right up
there with a sixth sense
good yes for me the first active split
was the weakest but each succeeding act
afterwards got better and better and it
built to a very intense finale that had
me holding my breath split is M night
Shyamalan best film since signs I am
very happy to say that and I'm going to
give it an A - one thing I do really
want to say is that I was actually blown
away by Sean Milan's opening speech to
this movie it was so humble because I
listened to a lot of directors
introduced their films during AFI and
this was the first speech in which a
director genuinely thanked the audience
for even being there he just seemed so
grateful and happy that he was able to
share his film with people he obviously
is loving what he's doing and I think
the past few years have really had an
impact on him because that was one of
the best opening speeches in fact it was
the best opening speech at all of AFI so
guys when this film does come out this
January a couple days after that I am
going to release a spoiler review and
I'll be able to discuss more things in
detail then up until then my lips are
sealed
go see this movie for sure it is worth
your time it's definitely one of the
better January movies ever that's for
sure and if you're curious on my
thoughts of every M night Shyamalan film
ever since the Sixth Sense I have
reviewed all of them and you're going to
get a link to a playlist in just a
second and you can hear my opinions on
every single M night Shyamalan film ever
since The Sixth Sense came out you guys
are the best thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes